in the previous episode Oh Oh what where
am I
nothing's good not very luxurious but
hey I like it
nah coughing you won't get hurt it's
like mom's got a girlfriend oh I don't
think so
how's it going bread my despair welcome
back to some more beyond 2 souls alright
let's continue
Jodi what the hell are you doing Jodi
you can't keep up now
why come I get why
what happened come on Jordy help
yourself
hey didn't got a bit of chocolate for
dessert
Charlie I don't reckon I remember what
that tastes like
what happened to you Stan I got in a
fight it wasn't for Jody I still be
lying hey have you seen it there were
four guys don't you kick yourself some
ass Jody does for Jody dues what what
why don't you why should I take
attackers did you know those guys yeah
see ya Skeets come down you're looking
for when we fight I got them phones with
cameras and
I guess I'd like to show off in friends
crazy [ __ ] many once
still haven't recovered what about the
Walter Walter how did you end up here I
was a high school teacher did I stop
being able to pay back the loans lost my
house my job on friends and it up here
on dead-end ride huh when is your baby
due next month
am she hasn't been chicken for days
no I hope she's all right
boyfriend used to beat her up you didn't
want a baby
you probably went killer
the [ __ ] is wrong with people alright
Tuesday Tuesday how did you get that
name that was a day I left home first
day of my new life how about you Jodi
yeah that much about yourself yeah how
did you end up on the street
some things that I'm not proud of what
did you do exactly until I realized I
was being used and I know that this is
gonna sound really strange by that I'm
I'm different
it's made my whole life [ __ ] mess you
said you were different Johnny
in what way
it's not important it doesn't matter
anymore
let's get up get our feet with our hands
and can we decided to talk to our Juice
are you okay
old Jamie from the ninth I'm so [ __ ]
cold
oh yeah we can heal people
but it's not easy
okay there you go
the pains gone you're welcome
how did she choose drugs lots of them
you're welcome sorry
Tuesday do you want to know how your
baby is oh she can shank with like
ultrasonic sound stuff give me your
hands
I just think that she's crazy I just be
like [ __ ] is out of her mind
don't worry about me
everything's all right yeah but how does
she know that she knows oh yeah I saw
her
ah I hate to ruin a nice moment but I've
done diddly dude that doesn't make sense
why did the other guy go right he was
sitting here right oh he's right there
my bad all right let's talk to him how's
you trust uh what the [ __ ] is I who the
hell are you man you scared me let me
say why Kangas join you all right stand
my love back Julie stop that that's not
funny it's been a long time Stan [ __ ]
up hey see Nick lazy kept you
it is me my love I never left
I've been here beside you all this time
my god it breaks my heart to see you so
lost some desperate I'm an empty without
you my love show it stop living in the
past stand
nothing's gonna change together now you
have to start a new life
go back to work fall in love just be
happy
please Dan do it for me Missy could help
me I miss you
stooop a.m. so she can say that's the
power of the rift huh
it's a miracle goddamn miracle that's
what I do
hoody
Thanks
but who's gonna help Jodi no one knows
oh [ __ ] the baby's coming
are we gonna deliver her baby are we
gonna deliver a baby Tuesday I always
wanted to deliver a baby
she's got contractions need an ambulance
we the whole goddamn Hospital I'll take
my baby
what would your wrist agate Jesus Christ
girl we ain't got nothin here
ain't got as much as a blanket hot water
we got nothing then go to a hospital
hold on hold on hold on calm down calm
down find a way I've had just put it out
there and just be like hey tell the road
always just assault abandoned building
figure out a way inside oh no way go
what do you sit when you stay here
Tuesday okay
Jody come on gotta go get everything we
need you girl don't be having no baby
till we get back alright don't you don't
don't you brother have no baby baby
before I get me oh [ __ ]
shit's gotta get going we're gonna
deliver her baby we're gonna deliver a
baby oh my God we're gonna be we get the
little bit of the baby
I can't believe with me delivering the
baby do you know doctor no we're just
writing like the [ __ ] away from her hate
for it anyway so what are we gonna do
listen just maybe have a chance your
tiny little changes up
and a dyke was in a bottle and decent
clothes like any other human being like
what were the people who died very rich
I won't okay so it's your plane I don't
have ha ha ha ha ha ha why get out come
on genius pith strikes again it's not
his responsibility I don't know this is
helping the delivery price just gotta
get in
goddamnit
there must be a way there must be a
[ __ ] way leave it to me huh
remember my super powers are you gonna
do just trust me
see she could literally have taken over
like a city actually could be the ruler
of Sweden if she wanted to but now she
let people use her and that's what a
strict security gate somewhere
switch to the security gate I thought I
saw something over here there it is
I press is skiing what about security
cameras
she can't be seen right not yet what he
says feels like me missiles
yeah yeah we missed something cameras
right there you go
save us some trouble reader how did you
do that
oops no time to explain let's just take
what we need and get out of here
yeah we're gonna deliver baby
baby juice thank you why don't you going
inside I took everything I could
Oh hurry my water broke
get into the building I told you about
yeah yeah Walters there sir come on we
need hurt
well damn they're fake guys wet huh
why is she never running ever be heard
of running Jodi it's like when you move
your legs really fast
oh well can't worry about that now we
got to deliver the baby I'm gonna
deliver that baby just like I the
opposite of what I did to that rift I'm
gonna do to the babies hole um okay then
I tried to make a joke and it now just
became really awkward the soundtrack
reminds me of Diane I feel like I heard
it before
all right which one l1 is hard to see
how did you get the the mom in there how
is she getting name is she walk she
can't walk when you're about to have a
baby
am I right or am I wrong tell me you're
wearing a thong oh yes I know because I
sang that song all night long baby good
all night no damn but should be around
just in time guys seems like it's gonna
be any minute now know what
anybody know what to do mmm I love you
except Jodie yes yes we got to deliver
that baby and we're gonna delivery good
know that I've never done anything like
this before
Oh me neither I just didn't want those
guys standing around staring at me
whenever actin but I can do it I can do
it uh okay uh-huh okay don't worry don't
worry we're gonna figure this out we're
gonna figure this out
I mean how hard can it be hey hey I'll
give you a Shell pill if I had one okay
here we carefully
okay we're delivering our baby breast
this is yeah oh god you ever shave I
mean what there's nothing you can do
whatever no really what am I supposed to
do okay I'm just gonna do a little dance
and then I'm gonna check here scissors
what the [ __ ] are you gonna do with a
surface no no I ain't cutting over JJ's
old mattress Oh
cuz it's gonna be okay hang in there
it's okay you can do it yeah I'm gonna
make this baby pop out just like
something else
come on bras just just breathe okay
yeah and I'll just wait for the
contractions to be one minute apart okay
now now now listen listen to me cozy you
gotta be sure you're fine I'm proud of
me okay
now squeeze out like you're having a
really really big [ __ ]
what I'm not pulling any fingers anyway
hell J Righetti bros double high-five
that's a baby born thanks to us now that
man out dog young
that's what the sisters oh of course
aah aah aah aah oh no aah
the graphics of rates are good for stuff
like this ah jeez what the [ __ ] is on
god damn it somebody job
oh yeah the mother cake I don't know
what you call it in English is how do
they usually have hair already I didn't
know I don't know I thought that were
bald
that's wait it's a suede there you go to
say you're very very welcome
so yeah that was pretty gross the butter
we're gonna make it
yeah but he just came out
okay night now you're kind of creeping
me out all of it I'll go get the others
I was like the best smoothest fastest
delivery ever hey if you need your baby
delivered just call pills no problem
I'll just charge a little extra I'll
need a lot of scissors wow it's so it's
a girl her name's Zoey [ __ ] and she got
damn amazing hey watch your language
Walter she understands everything you
say you want a baby eels just call peels
he's white knighting she's magnificent
ah I couldn't have done it without you
guys
no one can see you Jim D yeah especially
me because you know I did all the work
except the pushing part high five and
one
or me
right
Madison
and shampoo your hair Jody geez what's
happening now what's something yeah
Oh Oh what the [ __ ] the flame sticks so
amazing in this game seriously hey what
what happened the coming oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
hello Brooke Sam wake up
oh god where are the others Walter's on
this floor Jimmy and Tuesday and Zoey
are upstairs get out of here oh oh
that's not good
no I'm going alone I said get out of
here
Oh who did this
let's go upstairs Oh Shay oh we got to
help him first sorry I forgot about him
sorry man
oh it's too hot Hayden can do it you
know yeah I'm super fun thank you what's
that juicy juicy and the baby bear
upstairs we gotta save him before the
whole place burns down
I'm trying D don't need your life story
but she didn't tell him the cleaner to
door but that's okay
[ __ ] this place burn fast
are they in there
Oh Shay let's just please build out of
Lego come on
I didn't just excuse iDEN
I'm coming Jimmy Jimmy you're okay
job
oh come on Jimmy Jimmy come you can
you think of that movie who did you make
you are we gonna scare him
oh we're gonna take his body Yolo hey
what's up
get out now baby you gotta get the baby
next door
I was a mother gonna die no no I got a
feeling that the mom was gonna die no no
oh [ __ ] Thomas what is the other way
that way are you cereal on the mind
carry on
how do we got the door window open
oh it is a I didn't see oh [ __ ]
come on that baby and you're gonna die
Oh mate
Oh sh y l1
alright let's [ __ ] do this breath wah
yeah yeah come on let's get out of here
something Bad's gonna happen I know it
because I know it
this place is a [ __ ] mess yes
I didn't there we go
now we're not no we're not
you're gonna have to trust me okay
I don't trust myself what are we doing
here oh we're gonna charge your shield
ah focus focus on that a
break the wall break the wall yeah
make her go fires come on
go go Jody come on
right downstairs quick shits in pens may
intense I say
Oh
she can totally jump our job so now
we're just got to save our own skin huh
no problem no biggie
this is a regular Tuesday for me get it
ha ha ha
we're gonna go up
I thought that's a good idea but you
know
oh [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] BAE what are we do
jumping up oh yeah yeah dr. de planks
not today
yeah oh there's a notice are we gonna do
it have a good ear I'm ready with Nick
wait everybody
you only live once [ __ ] you oh [ __ ] I
thought she was gonna jump save me I did
edgert you're ruining a moment here
Yolo oh uh uh yes yes ball balls
Julie oh good you're alive that's how we
do it in the pitter-patter oh oh you did
there
the plan was incredible Oh so II how so
we good she's good huh put the fire out
damn Firestar yeah ah what's wrong with
people
tell your guys little gas and a lighter
and the Rope just pour out of the nest
I can hate happy endings see you again
[ __ ] hey don't you dad call me a [ __ ]
hey hey leave her alone John carlucci's
here on our [ __ ]
Oh bah did you get it in give it's in
the can come on let's go
what huh no no what's gonna what what to
what
Oh Shay what is wrong with people
don't eat my controller Anka
so she's going to the other side we need
oxygen
don't leave us Jody
don't leave
what oh no we have to wait until the
next episode hope you guys enjoyed
watching there like we did helps out a
lot I really appreciate it I'm so glad
you boys are digging this series it's
really fun and play thousand breasts
love you I'm not lying to anyone
gonna be like ha ha ha ha